[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight there are a lot of
things
you want to know about kamala harris we
plan to tell you
but the first thing to know about harris
is that in just a few months she could
run your country
if joe biden wins the presidential
election kamala harris effectively will
become the president of the united
states
everyone knows that democratic donors
understand it best of all
america's big banks have long controlled
joe biden for years in the senate for
decades he faithfully did their bidding
and in return they sent him money they
still do in fact far
more money than they send to the
incumbent president
and the banks were nervous for a moment
about the prospect that biden might pick
stacy abrams so they were thrilled when
he chose harris instead on twitter they
cheered the news
the consulting group signum global sent
a bulletin telling its clients to calm
down and rest
easy the democratic ticket is under
control
our control last night in fact the dnc
hosted a fundraiser with lobbyists for
credit suisse raytheon western using
union and exxon mobil
so all is well on wall street but how
about the rest of the country
actual voters have never shown a lot of
enthusiasm for kamala harris
in fact harris was so remarkably
unpopular in the democratic primaries
that despite non-stop media cheerleading
she was forced to drop
out before the first votes were even
cast before christmas
biden's handlers know this obviously
they were there they watched it but they
don't care
they're betting that you hate donald
trump so much
that you will make kamala harris
president anyway
like their friends at google the biden
campaign understands it has a monopoly
and they plan to exploit it this is not
the democracy we were promised in fact
it's not democracy
at all it's oligarchy and it has
consequences for everyone
if candidates are only accountable to a
small number of partisan executives in
new york and san francisco
they're unlikely to care when your
neighborhood police station is on fire
for example
they probably won't be too upset when
packs of mentally homeless take over
your street
when your nephew overdoses on fentanyl
they have no
incentive to improve your life in other
words and instead they can just lecture
you about your moral failings
and they are that's the system we have
now
kamala harris embodies it it's all
pretty sad
and unnerving if you think about it what
if we had an election and no one cared
what voters thought
we're about to find out but before you
get too depressed
take this moment to enjoy the
breathtaking absurdity of it all
the most oblivious politician in america
has joined forces
with the most calculating politician in
america
hilarity ensues neither one believes
anything but only one of them
knows what day it is when biden called
harris yesterday for example
there was a script visible on his desk
so the democratic nominee for president
is unable to speak to his running mate
without assistance here's how it went
hi hi hi sorry to keep you that's all
right
you ready to go to work
oh my god i'm so ready to go to work
first of all is the answer yes
the answer is absolutely yes
i am ready to do this with you for you i
i just i'm
just deeply honored and i'm very excited
that is just too great we're keeping
that on a loop in the tape department
i'm sorry to keep you kamala hara says
not since elizabeth warren pretended to
drink a beer with her husband
has an exchange that fake been captured
on video there are mexican soap operas
more authentic than what you just saw
and yet you still have to wonder how
many times do they have to reshoot that
scene before joe biden got his lines
right
let's try it again mr vice president
warm personal conversation take eleven
it's gonna be a deeply amusing three
months do your best to enjoy it
but as you do enjoy it pay attention
also to what harris says she believes
she'll try to say not much about what
she believes public policy is the last
thing the biden campaign wants to talk
about
the plan is to escape beyond harris's
historic status combined with of course
relentless attacks on the incumbent
the new york times for one is on board
the times doesn't think you should worry
about what harris plans to do to your
country
if she's elected moments after harris
joined the biden campaign the paper
declared her a quote
pragmatic moderate so why do they feel
the need to sum her up that way well
obviously to send a very clear signal to
everyone else
in the business at this late stage in
american journalism the new york times
exists primarily as an assignment editor
for producers at cnn
if the times declares it the 26 year old
vassar grads who decide what's on cable
television
faithfully repeat it so expect to hear
quite a bit about harris's pragmatic
moderation in coming weeks
you probably already are but the
question is that it's worth considering
is kamala harris actually a moderate
well let's see here she is last year
calling for congress
to change the constitution of the united
states so that
16 year olds can vote as you watch it
for the sake of argument pretend that
harris means what she's saying
and then ask yourself what kind of
person could make an
argument like that in public without
blushing
only someone who'd never actually met a
16 year old
do you believe that americans should
have the right to vote at age 16
i'm really interested in having that
conversation i have to tell you that
um i think that there is no question
that if we are looking at what is going
on in our country
we are putting more responsibilities on
people at a younger age
and the larger number of people that we
can
involve in the electoral process i think
the more robust it would be
there is no question harris says that
turning the government over to
10th graders would make the country more
robust
for sure no more school free dab pens
for everyone
endless possibilities for more
robustness
does harris really believe that a few
years ago she had this
assessment of young people watch
we mold and shape and direct someone to
become
a productive adult what's the other
thing we know about this population and
it's a specific phase of life remember
age is more than a chronological fact
what else do we know about this
population 18-24
they are stupid
she's right about that so put together
her two statements
on this subject young people are stupid
and that's why we need more of them to
vote
and it makes sense in fact when the
entire electorate is as passive as joe
biden has become
you can pretty much do what you want you
can wield total control that's what
harris is arguing
say what you will about that position
but it is not in any sense
moderate it's radical and many of
harris's views
are whether you like them or not
consider this tape in which she explains
how the federal government should
respond to the coronavirus pandemic
again
whatever you think of affirmative action
it's likely you never imagined
affirmative action would be applied to
life-saving medical treatment but kamala
harris thinks it should be
the disparities that have long existed
based on race
are now highlighted so one of the things
i'm calling for around this pandemic is
that we make decisions about where the
resources should go
based on that issue so we make decisions
about where the resources should go to
keep
people from dying on the basis
of skin color so only people of a
certain color get the vaccine for
example that's what she's arguing
now this is a lot of things it's immoral
it's unconstitutional
obviously but above all it is definitely
not
moderate nor is this by the way here's
harris in the senate from two years ago
telling the acting director of ice that
federal law enforcement officers
are a domestic terror group the klan was
what we would call today a domestic
terrorist group why
why why would we call them domestic
terrorist group because they
tried to use fear and force to change
political environment
and what was the motivation for the use
of fear and force based on race and
ethnicity
right are you aware of the perception
of many about how
the the power and the discretion at ice
is being used
to enforce the laws and do you see any
parallels
are you aware of the perception and do
you see any
parallels between federal law
enforcement officers
and the kkk harris wanted to know but
not
really the answer of course was embedded
in the question
ever notice you act a lot like hitler
harris wasn't really
asking anything she was attacking and
doing it in the sleaziest
most passive aggressive possible way but
don't fight back don't even think about
it because the only people who criticize
kamala harris are morally bad people
she's been making that very clear for
years she's even been
willing to attack her fellow democrats
last fall as her presidential campaign
began to collapse from
lack of popular support from voters
harris suggested the real problem
was that the democratic party her party
had too many racists in it
would i describe and what i believe to
be the elephant in the room about my
campaign
what is that electability what do you
mean electability you know essentially
is america ready for a woman and a woman
of color to be president of the united
states america was ready for
a black man to be president united
states and this conversation happened
for him
there is a lack of ability or a
difficult
a difficulty in imagining that
someone who we have never seen can do
a job that has been done you know 45
times by someone who is not that person
is america ready again it's all pretty
amusing and yes to answer a question
america is indeed ready for a black
president
we elected one twice but is america
ready for a
shallow hectoring rich lady whose only
real fans work at hedge funds and msnbc
that's the real question here but don't
expect anyone in authority to ask it
instead expect more lying more
propaganda
we're seeing it everywhere just in the
last 24 hours
in november for example the new york
times described kamala harris as quote
an uneven campaigner who changes her
message and tactics
to little effect and has a staff torn
into factions
but that's no longer true you know why
because it's election season it's time
to take out the orange menace
so the new york times has revised its
view harris is now quote
a political warrior shaped by life in
two worlds
and needless to say she's a pragmatic
moderate
the rest of the media vehemently agree
with this in fact they were so
excited about kamala harris getting in
the race that for a moment
they forgot to scream at their makeup
artists
i thought it was coming and it was
incredibly exciting news when it came
just a remarkable moment she cares about
women's issues she
she cares about equality deep within
her soul and she does have a you know a
kind of a charisma you know i don't want
to use the word celebrity but in
political terms she does
really a remarkable rise as nia malika
had pointed out there and as you pointed
out nia
she is a fighter she's smart she's quick
on her feet
she's articulate one of the the pluses
for a kamala harris candidacy
is her personal magnetism this is a
phenomenal pick tonight
people wanted to be around her there was
a charisma
a fascination for lack of a better word
anderson a bit of celebrity surrounding
kamala harris i immediately understood
why
people in california saw her as the
female
obama she's remarkable
really the question is if she gives a
campaign speech
from a position of elevation is it a
sermon on the mount
news at 11. the anchors on cnn of course
were especially
supportive in fact kamala harris is the
only politician their boss that tiny but
secretive jeff zucker
has ever publicly endorsed when she ran
for attorney general in the state of
california zucker said this quote
kamala is not just important for the
city of san francisco the state of
california
but for the entire country end quote
so according to jeff zucker kamala
harris is
that important existentially important
spiritually important probably too
important to cover as you would a mere
politician who just wants to
take over your country so stop asking
questions
obey